there was something you talked about a
little while ago about like sometimes I
noticed even you know growing up in a
poor white environment like a lot of
times they don't uh you know you feel
like you don't you feel like you don't
exist sometimes you know because there's
a there's a lot I feel like that in and
I didn't grow up in like a redneck place
you know I didn't grow up in like like
my mom my mother was a educated woman
you know like she's a hard worker but we
weren't like country you know like we
weren't like rebel flags or like you
know fish that could we just we're just
kind of regular people you know um and
sometimes it feels like when you're in a
community in a poor environment that the
hardest thing about the environment is
the environment itself you know it's
your Nate it's your neighbors even
though if they are your friends they
sometimes people don't want to see you
leave people want to see you change what
do you think some of the tougher things
in a black environment that uh that make
it the toughest to to leave it you know
to get out uh something really gotta
happen to you for you to leave cuz when
you give money most times you're not
leaving well yet and that's something
really happen you know I I had that
problem nice to feel like you know ain't
gonna know what is my city you know
ain't nobody I don't care what's going
on you know and a lot of people had that
frame of mind and it's the wrong frame
of mind as soon as you get money you
gotta go because uh cuz you've changed
the one who wanted to fight you now he
want to kill you right the policing
didn't know you he want to arrest you
because people have something to gain by
getting something over on you now right
right right right right uh and you get
hatred from the people who went to
school with you who feel like they had
and when those people shouldn't hate
when they had the same chances you right
but it's better to go to another city
where you'll get loved you know duck off
in a nice spot and work on your career
because uh I said over me I mean
times and most people get killed and
they own city and uh he's just saying
you know it's a dangerous job as a wrap
is it
we got them I feel like we got the most
dangerous job in the world
yeah cuz nobody want to kill a comedian
you know nobody I don't wanna kill look
at me nobody thinking I'm gonna gun this
mother nobody yeah if you don't hit this
punch line I'm taking a sword to this
[ __ ] you know nobody want to
kill a hockey player
yeah that's true man but do you get
scared then putting music out or do you
ever get worried that one of your past
songs created such a like a I'm a dog
you know that that it is that it might
have inspired somebody enough to be a
[ __ ] killer and now they're gonna
come it you know what I'm saying like
you ever worry that your music can
inspire like some John Lennon [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah like you could beat of like
John Lennon man that's a good song name
black John Lennon hey I don't know did
he was on a bicycle and somebody shot
him I think I just hate that uh you know
so many of my fans would come up on my
music idea now in is their I mean I know
in the black communities just uh I mean
this is obviously just from our
perception it's more it seems more
dangerous you know it seems more
dangerous is it exciting though
sometimes when there's more danger like
white white community is you gonna be
fine kind of broadly like you're gonna
have breakfast and shits probably gonna
be okay you know
it's normal it's not exciting it's
normal like violence is normal things
that happen in a hood it's really normal
cuz it's been happening since you were a
kid right so uh you see somebody
murdered at 8:19 all through your life
when you get 17 uh you're not gonna have
most respect for life probably gonna
have different perceptions of things
yeah either you're gonna turn you all
the way away all the way to that's the
perfect thing
yeah as in a hit because you once won
once you watch somebody get murdered
close to you you feel you can do even if
you didn't it even if you didn't do it
before you like somebody like you me
yeah yeah that's how that's how who the
babies are like well somebody takes
something you love you feel you can do
it cuz cuz you ain't seen it it's right
there you know you is like automatic
yeah you know well they're right you
know that's interesting so yeah and if
that's been going on for such a long
time then of course that feeling is
gonna be in people yeah yeah like
general right I fire yeah like I fire
that's heavy man that's intense [ __ ]
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one